[Music]
all right in today's very very special
episode
we're going to have
julia host this article that she has not
prepped for yeah
[Music]
surprise surprise ambush julia for
hosting you don't get a pay bomb don't
even ask you don't get it i know you're
a little bit traumatized but like
do not get a paypal have fun try to have
fun just be real serious and ask a ton
of questions no pressure no [ __ ] she
knows with that pressure yeah all right
uh in uh
model news oh she's bringing the old
school jk news
in model news all right submitted by
[ __ ] you jk news wow
the submissions
i don't know that was my username
only fans model raises 6.5 million in
two weeks to buy two football clubs
one 6.5 mill two weeks two weeks
oh a soccer team she bought two soccer
teams
i mean i'm not the
it's two right it's a sheep wow
what so what happened
it's a she right yeah yeah a playboy
model is using her only fans page to
drum up funds in hopes of buying a
professional football team which is the
soccer team yes yes but but she's bought
two teams yeah two of them that's kind
of cheap right like you she got two for
one of you is she about she's not buying
like [ __ ] barcelona anymore these
things are about to get relegated bro i
hear that's bad in uk talk oh yeah that
sounds bad you earn eight million
dollars on only fans in just a few weeks
what's your content like wow
yeah what's her yeah this this does she
do a niche like i'm gonna eat [ __ ]
popsicles while i like jack myself off
or so she's sitting on balloons
[Music]
dude people love sitting on board
sitting on balloons and sitting on
birthday cakes
6.5 million only fans
created i think people sit on birthday
cakes this is a birthday game
a lot i love it
that's an interesting niche yeah it
really
yeah
this is her
okay
she's got the instagram model look
is her name there what's her name she
looks korean
really
the blonde hair and blue eyes thing kind
of threw me off there's something going
on there she looks she looks classy
yeah
daniella is her name
she looks like a playboy model i'll say
that yeah good for her like the half
days
yeah the good old days the classics so
she probably doesn't do like porn porn
on her only fans right like she's not
like
maybe doing boy girl [ __ ] or nothing hey
how did she get eight million
does she do it like hey i'm trying to
buy a like sports team let's crowdfund
it and in return you get [ __ ] picks
for those fans like damn that makes a
lot of sense that's a good fundraiser i
would never pay for a [ __ ] pick would
you guys pay no dude nah that's what
google images for it is like nancy
pelosi maybe oh i'm paying for that i
pay for that maybe if it was like a
sonogram of my wife or some [ __ ] a sonic
grab that kind of that kind of [ __ ]
you want to
see the depth imagine if that's filed
under the same thing the doctor's like
you know you're gonna have to fork up
for some [ __ ] pictures
doctors like her
against my principle one of the doctors
like like yo man that's [ __ ] that's
my ip right there dude that's my artwork
and i don't want it to be [ __ ] cheap
just having a doctor casually talk like
that like when he shows it to y'all want
to print out of this [ __ ] pic
that's my costume like for memories
like medical reasons or something yeah
miscellaneous reasons you want a high
quality print of this or you ask for a
print they're like oh no we don't print
[ __ ] pics here [ __ ] perv what do you
think this place is we print him next
door he's like this is an outdoor
doctor's office don't you know
a tour
like a kovic clinic i get it
oh so yeah i see okay yeah i don't know
it doesn't say exactly what kind of
content she posts on only fans but
she is a big fan of the teams that she
bought so she just wants to be able to
put like um like her her her weight into
it she buying minor league soccer teams
so can she potentially ruin those teams
well i mean for her she's such a big fan
that she wants to
raise this money to help um the team
level up
new equipment yeah
sounds like your equipment so it sounds
like she's the only fan that's also a
fan
of
another team so she only found herself
so she could only fan a team yep yeah
inception
you know what's wild tom brady and
gizelle could honestly sell a sex tape
and probably raise enough money for him
to buy an nfl team
like i actually think that's possible
yeah who wouldn't pay for that i would
see it that's pretty that that'll
probably get more money than the super
bowl to be honest i guarantee you yeah
do you think you think tom [ __ ] lays
it down i think tom has to do but which
team can he buy though
the jaguars like
like not like the patriots right well
dude because even like small market
teams like the colts right yeah 3.6
billion
for the team
small market team bottom 10 because they
generate so much [ __ ] cash yeah the
nfl doesn't well because they do they
share the revenue too so like there's
like 32 teams right and they're all
sharing all that revenue yeah that's
crazy so i'm i'm guessing these are more
like uh private clubs right because yeah
for sure because i think that gotta be
minor league or something that was on
this club was 20 million 20 million what
if we just like get into a sports that's
still new a niche one and then get all
the teams early because that's like
stuff that's like mine
that's like buying like crypto early
early that's what we need to do
you know
yeah something like ping pong [ __ ] like
like the ping pong [ __ ] league yeah
yeah that would be big movers with that
yeah something niche something like new
you know yeah yeah yeah
we got a big tossing sounds wild
you've never heard of the ping pong
[ __ ] show in thailand
do you mean the one where they shoot
ping pong they shoot ping pongs yeah so
you want to make a league for them
yeah business league what about
non-binary dunk contest
non-binary dunkers that's interesting
that's cool can we raise and lower the
hoops
like with the electronic equipment
it's just constant it's like mini golf
it just keeps going up and down i like
that just on a hydraulic oh it's like
when you go to the arcade and you play
the game and it just keeps coming back
and forth and it's just you stubborn
[ __ ] what about mini golf that's
the size of
like maxi golf where it's like a whole
course
but it takes [ __ ] all afternoon 17
strokes for one
mini golf but just with the driver
wow
i don't know i don't know what the
difference is it's a little bit bigger
of a hole how about a driving range that
you can shoot it from both you can hit
from both sides and you're trying to hit
other people like dodge balls
what about you put that [ __ ] on a boat
and then if you do move you [ __ ] you
go in the water
[Laughter]
so it's boat versus boat now we're
thinking
that's sid meier's pirates yep we gotta
be game disruptors man like i think i
think i think they're on to something
with this whole vip golf [ __ ] like it's
like you take something that already
exists
and then oh live golf live eagle yes
okay i like vip golf yeah
it seems more red carpet yeah golf
sounds like i'm like a cocktail waitress
is going to offer to blow me in the
bathroom yeah and i'm into that i like
that golf league yeah that's the idea of
it i don't want to tarnish my brand with
like making it too sexual oh so i think
um
something
more
like family friendly damn
that's interesting how you were just
saying like i don't want to tarnish it
in that way because for her she raised
up all this money for this team right
and she she's like basically i think the
best way to look at it is that she's a
fan of this team and she wants this team
to win and so she's raising money for
them um and she hopes to be like more
involved into it right
but the team itself are saying like we
can reduce no we never planned on
sitting down and talking with her oh
she raised the money on her own
thing i think he's in there is he in
there
nice son of a [ __ ] he's so elusive
sorry julia what reason
it's true though we almost had him
yeah so uh so the team was saying like
oh yeah we never planned to like sit
down and talk with her about this oh
really for her she's like now she's like
oh my god you guys are just like so
sexist like you guys like don't like the
way that i raised funds in such a unique
way
um so they're like sorry we can't take
that [ __ ] money dude like they're like
um
are always complaining
well every club kind of has a right to
decide like who's buying into them right
i take dude if i was a team that needed
funding i'd be like drug money [ __ ]
sex money like just money money like you
know because i see it as when i get that
money
when you when i get it i'm gonna turn it
to good money oh you're laundering it
you're gonna buy a plane you're
laundering it for christ yeah
you think [ __ ] you think churches be
like i ain't taking that devil cash they
ain't saying that [ __ ] they'll be like
this is where we launder it to good
money this is you give me all that bad
money and then i will [ __ ] buy
gold [ __ ] like platforms i'll make a
gold jesus i'll turn it into you know
yeah how many gold jesus is you [ __ ]
need
us
i'll make a gold everything man that's
what they do is like they turn it into
pure money um
yeah remember that story about jesus
coming in and then he flips over the
table
and then later on
they make the churches out of gold yup
plot twists right they talk about jesus
in there and then they probably like
it's like reading a bedtime story it's
like yeah and then you know jesus was
really cool and then he went and then
flipped to the table but like you know
whatever like whatever whatever whatever
uh whatever you guys oh
hey don't have sex if you're gay
don't masturbate don't masturbate hey
men are women
submit to your husband yeah
[ __ ] crazy dude
but yeah so uh she's pretty trying to
pretty much put them on blast about
playing like
you're being sexist or whatever and then
the team responded by saying like um we
don't like we yeah basically like we
kind of have the choice of like who we
want to be like a part of it but like
they're just saying that we haven't
opened up the discussions
to uh decide if we wanted to sell the
team to once whole i think that's fair
to say
that that's fair to say and it's also
fair that for everybody who was hoping
or donating money to her so she could
buy the football club if she can't even
buy it she it's fair she keeps the money
too sure yeah that's crazy you get like
800 dollars worth of [ __ ] that's what
i was saying make her own team make your
own team [ __ ] yeah that's definitely
responsible business if you if you're
like a franchise owner or whatever and
someone out there saying yeah i'm
raising money to buy the team but you
don't have a predetermined discussion
you should say oh by the way that's just
their initiative and we haven't we're
not ready to sell you know that's like
that's fair yeah but what if i'm like yo
i'm gonna buy this [ __ ] big mac and
then you go to mcdonald's and they're
like we never talked about it
we never [ __ ] talked about this [ __ ]
joe why the [ __ ] are you coming in here
with this
expectation to buy a baby there's no
point
dude they want you to buy it
it's a similar thing it's the same exact
idea
uh yeah you're right yeah i missed that
this is you or someone brag about buying
a big mac bag
i'm gonna buy a big mac i gotta bring
that too
it was let's get a big macs today we
lost ourselves i've never seen somebody
smiling while eating mcdonald's before
but every time i see the commercial
that's all they're doing
mcdonald's i do feel sad yeah dude i'm
enjoying it
i'm [ __ ] happy as [ __ ] i'm enjoying
it but it's smiling though yeah yeah
smiling bruh yeah i'm the only one
that's doing it and it's night time i
feel instantly guilty yeah i feel like
well it's me and the homeless guy over
there having a full-on conversation with
his imaginary friend that's having the
blast everyone else you got the [ __ ]
family where you don't know why the
three-year-old's up at two in the
morning you have the [ __ ]
bag lady in the side everyone else looks
pretty sad except for you know maybe me
and
the homeless guy and his imaginary yeah
yeah having a great conversation a
heated discussion yeah pop quiz jk yeah
what's the most valuable sports
franchise in the world i just read this
like yesterday
sport you mean like a league or like a
sports franchise team
or the team across all sports across all
sports oh you give us a hint of like is
it american or uk based i think it's
soccer
yeah i feel like it's soccer it's got to
be soccer or something oh it's probably
not even american barcelona
it's up there but no what is it what is
it
madrid
dallas cowboys dallas
6.5 billion dollars all in their
jumbotron yeah dude it's [ __ ] wow
barcelona and i think arsenal are up
there though really yeah wow
and then ryan may is up there too what
makes them profitable like they just get
a lot of ticket sales or
revenue ticket sales merch all that [ __ ]
bro
that's true because a lot of mexican
gangsters they really like that stop the
cowboys dude hey they're called
america's team for a reason right like
they sell the most merch for sure
interesting yeah
i didn't know that i thought it was
gonna be some soccer team and texas i
mean as populated as it is and the pride
they have in their team that makes sense
yeah plus they the competition's what
the texans yeah [ __ ] and it's not
only mexican gangsters crips crips
they'll target that market dude they got
the though too you got raiders oh yeah
yeah that's gonna eat into that market
for sure that's true that's true
that's a funny way of looking at market
analyses like i like your product but
how are crips gonna feel about it
you